Kathy is with us in South Carolina hi
Kathy how are you hi good how are you
better than I deserve what's up good
good well so me and my husband are
having a baby in August and we've caused
our debt snowball to build up cash one
of our time yeah so we have a good
amount but one of our cats has a sort of
medical emergency and the surgery is
going to be anywhere from like two to
five thousand dollars depending on if we
go to a specialist or have our vet do
the best she can quote unquote so my
question is somewhat of an ethical one
is there ever a limit you would put on
spending on a pet depending on where you
are financially well I'm just an animal
lover I just we I just cry every time
one of our dogs dies you know I just cry
like a little girl I mean I just I love
animals my wife grew up on the farm and
animals went away every week so she
loves animals but I I'm I I treat them
like people you know so it's harder for
me emotionally is for her if a dog dies
she just like well that's sad the dog
died and with me I like cry you know and
so you know you kind of have to get into
it in its personal finance but I I think
you got a you know it is an animal it's
not a person and personally the way I
look at it and everybody can look at it
however you want to look at it y'all can
all everybody always gets mad at me
every time this question comes up but I
get always hate-mail long Twitter but
you know but but you know if you have a
new baby coming that is an that is a
real obligation a cat is not and so if
you're going to spend $5,000 on a cat
you should probably be worth several
hundred thousand dollars and you're not
okay okay we have we were gonna I was
actually gonna go back on the debt
snowball because we we can't we have
like about ten thousand now right now
I'm just kind of preparing for that but
I was like that seems like maybe too
much
just to have on him for the baby so it's
like we have this too much to have on
hand for the baby steps but you're
building up cash that you're going to
use on this debt snowball as soon as you
and baby come home from the hospital
healthy yeah you're not building it up
to spend $5,000 on a cat yeah so another
way to look at it is this in the and
this is again it's it's it's breaks your
heart okay so I'm not I'm not acting
like this doesn't matter it does matter
I'm the guy that cries okay so I'll cry
when I'll cry when Kitty goes to Kitty
heaven you know but not me because I'm
not a cat guy but I'll cry when Dawg he
goes to doggy heaven okay so but aside
from that if you didn't have a cat would
you buy a cat for $5,000 right now no
right now I would not necessarily and so
and I feel guilty because I do I like
the cat but it's a baby of my you know
like I have a cat that I love and this
cat the other one I haven't bonded with
Sun trying to be really fair and well
it's not that's not that there's if it
were the cat you loved it's the same
decision it's a cat not a baby yeah
they're different these are not humans
human life is different than animal life
and so we love our animals and we're
kind to them and good to them and they
have the better life than most humans if
they live at the ramsey house or at your
house right but you know that they're
loved and cherished but you know we had
a pug one time that there was a 2500
they said he's got spina bifida and it's
gonna be 2500 bucks to have a 15% chance
that this dog can walk and I'm like I'm
not putting the dog through that and I'm
not spending 2500 bucks on the dog and
so that dog went to heaven
and I cried harder than anybody else in
the family but their BIOS just went well
the dog died but Dave just falls into
the basket right but that's okay still
make the decision that's called
leadership I'm sorry
are you facing this